a new jump in coronavirus cases pushes
the total number of infected americans
to nearly 8 million since the pandemic
began
that includes more than 680 000
infections reported
in just the past two weeks the newest
victims include a top college football
coach
alabama's nick saban announced yesterday
he has tested positive
molalengi is following the renewed
outbreaks
six-time national champion coach nick
saban of the alabama crimson tide has
been sidelined by the coronavirus
as has the school's athletic director
but saban says
as of now there's no indication of a
team-wide
outbreak we toast our players every day
i get tested every day
i feel fine i felt time i was very
surprised
in august tuscaloosa's mayor shut down
bars for two weeks as cases spiked
following students return to campus a
move saban publicly supported
he's been outspoken about the need to
follow public health guidelines
even appearing in covid prevention psas
i told you you have to wear a mask when
you're in this building after having
thousands of students test positive on
campus during the first month of
classes the university of alabama is now
reporting fewer numbers
but that's not the case for most u.s
states coronavirus cases are on the rise
in 37 states
and hospitalizations are rising in 42
states
wisconsin opened this field hospital
just outside milwaukee on wednesday
to handle patient overflows the state's
hospitals are at 85 percent capacity
and covet related hospitalizations are
at an all-time high
many of our icu's are strained and every
region of our state has
one or more hospitals reporting current
and imminent staff shortages health care
worker and covid survivor deb summick is
losing
faith in the state's ability to turn
things around
we can't come to an agreement this state
right now
is so incredibly divided and we've
turned a health pandemic a health
crisis into a political thing
right now the u.s is averaging more than
50 000
new coronavirus cases every single day a
number that dr anthony fauci says
is unacceptably hot he also urged
americans who are making
thanksgiving holiday plans to be very
careful when getting together with loved
ones it's those small gatherings that
have increasingly become linked
to covid transmission fauci says he
himself
will not be getting together with his
own children over the holiday
out of an abundance of caution tony
it'll be a very different thanksgiving
wall thank you very much